the family is the building block of
society so anything the movement has to
well Reagan played a role in the
destruction of the American family with
no fault divorce he didn't do it himself
overnight man there was a lot at work
there but um I think it was yeah
it was it's it's hard to say with the
final nails but that was definitely very
bad very bad no fault no fault divorce
ended marriage it formalized it
formalized our ending of marriage but
there were other things like there was a
massive cultural shift that happened at
this time so previously people thought
of divorce as something that was
horrible but that we should allow in
certain circumstances and I'm not even
saying that's the correct vision because
my I I just don't believe a marriage can
actually end if it's an actual marriage
but uh that's not to say someone who's
being abused can't go live somewhere
else but my main point is there was
there was uh there was a there was a uh
reinvention that happened culturally or
around the time of the 1970s where
people stopped viewing divorce as this
unfortunate thing that happened
sometimes and that we should allow a
political outlet for and they they
started reframing it as an adventure a
method of self-exploration a way to
reinvent yourself rather than like
something horrific that we should
prevent from from ever well I mean some
people say it's um birth control if you
look up yeah divorce rate and like birth
control like the rate of women on birth
control it's really interesting the the
charts are the same pretty much whoa
yeah well it all plays a role you could
look it up and like put it on the screen
it's really interesting it's like
literally if you put them side by side
it's the same I love it uh but I smell
different I would say like social media
too because I I think like yeah because
I mean you get like all these women that
think they're hotter than they are
because they have the simps messaging
them every single day Instagram filters
yeah so I think like it would be silly
to not include that in like the
destruction of the family also is that
the destruction these women can't these
women still hook up with those Sims that
are messaging them what do you mean like
what about the fact that guys are
hitting on these women is different from
reality because it makes it a global
sexual Marketplace so it's not she
doesn't just have access to the men like
in her town because before it's like the
prettiest guy prettiest girl in the town
marry each other whatever now it's like
the men are competing with men from you
know Dubai like celebrities like how
many women has you know a celebrity like
Drake slept with we actually future
future wives you know what I mean we've
talked a lot about this uh I've and boy
it doesn't trigger the feminists I
talked about how uh dating apps oh that
too basically caused a major collapse
because what happens is it used to be
that if you were a dude you had access
men and women had access to their school
basically the institution where they
spend all their time so a guy is 18 he
goes to college and he has access to the
women in the college network which is
mostly the college he's at and then
maybe the friends of friends yeah but
when dating apps emerge all of a sudden
all of these you know 18 plus young
women have access to 25 year old plus
men who aren't in college but have cars
have jobs have salary and now the 18
year old in college has to enter has to
compete with a guy who's already got a
career and has already established and
they can't yeah I think it's it's really
important that you pointed out birth
control because that plays a massive
role in the way that we've been
restructured in terms of our thinking
about sexuality so people used to
recognize that the purpose of sex was
unity and procreation right and you
wanted to be with the person you were
going to be with the rest of your life
before you engage in that act with them
because it makes new people and someone
has to take responsibility for those new
people
what artificial contraceptives made
possible was a rerouting of our
Collective cultural thinking about
sexuality which took it from something
that was to be revered that was
beautiful that needed social
restrictions and something that was just
about the pleasure of the individual and
that only needed to be considered within
the context of pleasure without actually
considering its actual broader purpose
which is the creation of families and of
course families are the building block
of society so when you corrupt people's
sexual morals you end up destroying the
entire Society inevitably I mean if you
don't end up setting that that train
back on the the rail or putting things
back in the proper course it all falls
apart you you just can't do it
um and you know we recognize this
economically whenever a Marketplace is
deregulated we say well this is going to
result in unbearable inequalities all of
the spoils will go to some small
percentage of people who happen to have
the traits that the market rewards but
then when it came to the sexual
Revolution no one was willing to say
that well when it comes to the sexual
Marketplace deregulating it is going to
create unbearable terrible inequalities
and in the end people aren't going to be
happy I get the feeling that if we made
birth control illegal and made abortion
illegal it would cause Devastation like
it would cause a bunch of spousal abuse
like a lot of the the value of I can't
stand no-fault divorce I mean it makes
me I lost faith in marriage basically I
have no faith in that institution
because she can leave whenever she wants
but if they're stuck then won't they
just be getting beat a lot
um so if well this is the whole point of
no fault divorce is a person could get
divorced if they demonstrated that there
was some kind of abuse occurring right
and this is part of what I was saying
earlier I believe marriage is life long
but that doesn't mean that you can't go
live somewhere else if a person is
abusing you right that doesn't mean you
don't go and go to the police well and
the one thing too they've expanded the
definition of abuse so much that we
don't even know what abuse is anymore
like it's not just like that you can
include like Financial abuse because I'm
doing a divorce documentary and and so
um it's going into like basically men
that get financially ruined by divorce
and the issue is like they literally
like expanded the definition so much to
include things like Financial abuse so
if I'm married and he says you can't
spend five thousand dollars on my credit
card he's financially controlling me and
that's considered abuse and family court
you need to give in the U.S percentage
of your income UK um us is state by
state wow so like this is this is based
in the UK well words are violence now so
yeah exactly do you think there's faith
in marriage do you have faith in
marriage well I don't think marriage is
marriage anymore
like I I think that marriage it's a
whole different institution it's
basically just long-term relationships
nowadays it's dating I think that's
there's truth in that yeah because like
if you can get out like how is it
marriage I think the way is marriage
doesn't exist since no-fault divorce
yeah I I would argue that in the United
States our laws don't properly recognize
marriage of course I believe marriage
still exists but the way the culture
understands it you're not looking at
actual marriages in a sense because the
person isn't truly saying uh For Better
or For Worse till death do we part
they're saying I'm just going to do this
for a while until I get bored about like
if if divorce is in your mind as an
option it's something you're willing to
consider and you're not saying there is
no one else for me for the rest of my
life or this person's life then are you
really getting married there's a in the
service industry I used to work as a
waiter for like a decade and when we
would finish a shift I'd marry the
condiments and be like okay take the
ketchups and marry them together which
means mix I'd pour one into the other
shake it up you could never undo that
that mix is permanent now one flesh the
two became one flesh and what what does
a guy get out of marriage that he
doesn't get out of a long-term
girlfriend if she can leave her half her
money yeah well again I think the um hey
what do you mean half her money yeah
wasn't the story with Russell Brand that
when they got he got divorced from Katy
Perry he didn't take anything from her
because they're both super rich and he
didn't care yeah well I mean but women
get money the majority of the time so
it's not like men get money out of it
yeah like I think I think women only get
spousal support like 10 of the time uh
when it comes to child like child
custody women get the kids 90 of the
time yeah so it's really an unfair
system totally agreed so your question
has two different answers right when you
ask what do men get out of marriage
because in some sense like yes when
you're talking about our society when
you're talking about what we are calling
marriage I mean because the institution
yeah yeah if we're talking about what
marriage actually is it's a different
question right I mean because it's again
it's it's not moral to have sex with
someone you're not married so you
shouldn't be having sex with someone
you're not married to in a culture where
people are having sex outside of
marriage where they're living together
when they're not married you're correct
that uh it doesn't seem from like a
material perspective that anything is
really added to the relationship by
entering into a legal Union with each
other well even when you look at like
you know Purity and youth like men don't
even get that anymore out of marriage
like in the UK the average age of first
marriage for a girl is 31. and why like
Purity like what percent of women do you
think were virgins in 1920.
um many more than today I don't know if
it was 100 but it was there there's been
surveys done and many more women I mean
you don't know like people can lie but
it was like 85 of women
um did not like they said their virgins
on their wedding day like what is that
today so what what does a guy get from
Marriage yeah so he doesn't get Purity
doesn't get youth um now she has the
power to take I mean but that's that is
more of a traditionalist argument that
doesn't I don't think matters
materialistically or
um what I'm saying is there are
certainly people who care about purity
and all that stuff I don't think the
average person thinks like is my wife
pure but a lot of guys probably do yeah
what I'm saying is you go to a guy and
say Hey you know that long-term
relationship you're in yes why don't you
get married okay why well if you do you
open up the door to losing half of
everything you own if things go bad and
nothing else changes what does the woman
get the woman gets half your stuff if
she decides to leave at any point well
but this is also the point right the
left Marxist they they hate marriage and
they hate the family so people look at
how the culture has been oriented and
they look at these no fault divorce laws
and they say oh my goodness there's no
point in even getting married anymore
well that was by Design like the entire
purpose was to dissuade people from
wanting to get married that was the long
game that was the long game and make it
and so I think our marriage is okay
exactly right because if if sex before
marriage is on the table then you can
have that without committing to a person
I mean what are most men gonna choose
even if you don't have these wacky
divorce laws well all the divorcing
America's side I find it weird to say
that sex before marriage is bad because
like if you have if you don't if you
have sex a girl and you don't like it
but you don't know that until after
you're married that'd be horrible well
sex isn't tryouts right and she's a
person and you're a person and that's an
act that creates human people and it'll
create a person even if you didn't think
the sex was uh all that great I think
that two people
who are married should should try uh to
communicate with one another so that
they can you know meet each other's
needs in illicit way and uh I think
we've created so many problems with no
fault divorce in this sexual Evolution
and sex outside of marriage to say that
you know a solution to that problem
isn't good enough because it might
interfere with some people's ability to
have sexual pleasure doesn't really
convince me well and it's not even about
like moral like good or bad it's like
what outcomes does what outcomes does
this have and like the studies show that
the best outcomes are from two people
that are both virgins
but the best outcomes of marriage yeah
and marriage satisfaction how would you
know if the sex was bad if you didn't
have sex with anyone else exactly that's
the same exact argument feminists make
they were like wow that must suck
condemning your life to bad sex because
you live this puritanical way yeah yeah
okay yeah but again that's that's a
horrible way of viewing sex it's a
horrible way of ignoring other people
and well it's not just that ignorance is
bliss it's that there are some things
you have no need to know but right like
it doesn't there is some information
that's not going to make you happier
there are a lot of things that all of us
could know that we don't want to know
because it would make us miserable the
five-minute orgasm would be awesome like
if you could have non-stop orgasms with
your wife like it's just you could do
like two hours of tantrics do you think
with sex outside of marriage that's
happening for people because the studies
show that people rate lower marital
satisfaction rates when they've had more
sexual partners prior to marriage have
you ever have you ever watched any
romantic comedy yeah like the Trope is
that the women are always unsatisfied
like the guys are in it for a one-night
stand it's wham bam
well and also they're not to get I mean
since we're already having an adult
conversation here they have done studies
with Rams right so this is something
that I learned when I was looking into
the effects that pornography has in the
brain and how men will seek out novelty
and they found
with these Muse that they were studying
that men finished more quickly with a
newer partner okay so exactly so I I
don't think I have to elaborate any
further on the implications of that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time